hi everyone this is jeremy shifting at
khan academy
happy monday i hope you had a restful
weekend or at least as restful as we can
get under these circumstances
um and i want to thank you for joining
us early this week for a great
conversation with mark laser who's
bringing expertise not only as a khan
academy ambassador
so someone has used the site really
deeply in his own school but also as
someone who's been using it
in a cyber school environment for years
now and so really can speak to the
sort of new world order that we've all
found ourselves in we're trying to teach
across the great divide
and reach our students wherever they are
so mark thank you so much for joining us
today
and as folks have probably gathered from
previous sessions
we're going to do a little bit of an
interview just to get started and then
we're going to turn it over to the
audience for some live questions to
finish up but before we get there
i would love to know more about your
background as an educator
and then specifically with khan academy
sure happy to share that and uh thanks
jeremy and uh
i just wanted to say to everybody that's
participating we're all in this together
and if there's anything we can do to
help each other get through the uh the
current
situation we're in uh reach out to each
other and we'll do that
um i think jeremy mentioned there's
about 500 people online now so i guess
we can't introduce ourselves
now uh but yeah thanks jeremy i'm glad
i'm glad to be part of this
um my background isn't hey mark here's
one thing we can do really quick if
you're curious
sure would you rather know what grade
level folks teach or what subjects they
teach or i can ask both if you're
curious
yeah i think both would be very
interesting for sure let's do a very
quick poll here
so hopefully you're seeing on your
screen now the chance to choose your
grade level
this will just help mark really tailor
his comments to the specific uh
challenges you may be facing so go ahead
and fill out that
um if anyone is having audio issues
you're probably not hearing this but
there is
a message in the chat that will give you
a number to dial in
and i will replace that for your benefit
okay so thank you everyone for filling
that out so quickly
we'll go ahead and close that poll we
now have 640 people online which is
amazing
82 percent of you voted within 10
seconds awesome
we're going to show those results and so
what we're seeing right now mark is that
it's 40
elementary 25 percent middle 26
high and 9 other okay definitely
a nice split but with a little skew
towards elementary yep
and then we'll do the same for the
subjects we'll go ahead and launch that
and again my apologies for not including
every possibility here
um as you are discovering in your own
sort of teaching practice there are
definitely limitations to what
technology offers so
we are trying to make do as best as
possible but yeah let us know what
subjects you teach
and we will use those to tailor upcoming
content
okay we'll close this out in a second i
have to say
mark if ever there was a recruiting
ground for future jeopardy contestants
this would be it
because people are digging those buzzers
quickly you're at 78
of the vote and it's looking like 46 are
teaching all
not surprising for the elementary crowd
okay right sure a huge chunk teaching
math
and certainly that's how khan academy
got its start yep and then a smattering
across social studies
ela science and others um and we can
speak to those as well
time allow so that being said i'm sorry
to cut you off before mark but please
tell us more about yourself oh no
problem at all i've been teaching in a
cyber environment for about 10 years
prior to that i was a strategic account
manager for corning so i
worked in the business world for um
about 20 years and then uh left when it
was time to
start student teaching when i was
getting my master's in elementary
education so
got some experience in the business
world and some experience in the
teaching world
but have specifically been teaching in a
excuse me a cyber environment for about
the last 10 years so this is our
this is our sweet spot there's me
um so yeah if you just want to flip to
the next slide i can uh con
kind of uh uh you'd asked about why
we're using uh why we're using khan
academy and why i'm using khan academy
as an educator
um about four years ago i'd been using
khan
pretty heavily up until that point we we
had a pretty uh traumatic
rollout of a of a new curriculum that
had been designed exclusively for our
school
um it was kind of problematic so um what
we decided to do
was uh uh focus on um i was already
using khan academy pretty heavily to
start with i decided to
put all my wood behind one arrow as they
say and and
build my entire curriculum my
assessments my homework and everything
around khan academy so
um i've used khan a lot over the past 10
years but i'm almost exclusively khan
academy to teach eighth grade math
uh for about the last four years
and in terms of how you teach we'd love
to hear more about what that looks like
day to day even before this whole crisis
started
right yeah i wanted to share this with
you because i think you'll find it
doesn't look that much different than
what a brick and mortar teacher's
schedule would look like
you know a morning session where we have
prep and then some
targeted learning time for for students
and then i teach
three 50-minute blocks of math uh nine
o'clock at ten o'clock eleven o'clock
break for lunch uh afternoon is set
aside for um
uh meetings planning iep that sort of
thing um i
in fact just came to this meeting from
office hours so i have office hours with
students where
they can stop by to ask questions about
anything that
they didn't get in class in the morning
and then the end of the day is set aside
for a planning
and grading so it really doesn't look it
doesn't look that much different we do
teach asynchronous classes so
excuse me synchronous classes so i
actually do have a room full of students
in front of me
every day and if if you're unfamiliar
with how we teach in the cyber
environment it actually looks exactly
like what jeremy is
is sharing here my lesson each day is
um pretty much a powerpoint presentation
i prepare slides every day and go
through with um
the lesson for the day uh questions from
the previous day
data about how students are are doing
and we have interactive tools just like
we do in this session where students can
communicate we can
we can talk back and forth to each other
one of the questions i get a lot jeremy
and i don't know if
if you want me to jump in that now or i
can focus on pretty much any slide you'd
like me to uh
to address here were you going to speak
to the grading piece or
um sure yeah that that came up in
another session with mr vandenberg
session he
addressed grading and how he grades by
uh he grades by
uh progress and i've hit on this way
that i think works pretty well for me
i use the assignment feature heavily and
what i'll do is post weekly assignments
typically about five per week if we have
a five day week i'll
i'll post an assignment that's due every
day and i assign each one a standard
point value typically 10 points so
there'll be 50 points worth of con
assignments in a typical week
um then when i say grade once twice and
then per
student request once the due date has
has arrived
i will grade and you can see a the
typical score that i are not typical
scores but this is what my grading would
look like
for this student she would receive 10
points on each of those so she'd get 50
points for the week i'd look at that i'd
look at that once
i'd load that score in the gradebook for
that student i typically go back and
look at it one more time you'll give
them a chance to turn in any late work
and khan has a really great feature
jeremy if you could go to settings
[Music]
here we go
settings and then download csv that
allows you to download all of the work
that students have done
since since you created the class and
what i can do is use that to
extract data that was done since the
last time i grade it so i don't have to
go through the entire grade book and
grade again i can just pick the students
that completed work since the last time
i looked at the
since the last time i looked at the
gradebook and it's it's turned out to be
a pretty efficient way to grade so i
i grade one so i have the bulk of the
grading that i do
i go at it again to pick up any
stragglers that there might be and then
if students turn in any light work it's
it's on them to notify me
and i can do updates the grade based on
that
the reports that are available i think
you just started to hit on one
um you were going to scores right so
there's some really cool reports you can
get out of
the assignment function and con you've
got the actual
scores themselves you can go in and see
how students did
on particular assignments and also
um could you pop over to oh good yep so
you can see
how students and what what jeremy is
showing right here
could you go back to manage so we look
at the report for
a particular assignment when i mentioned
putting my slides together for a
particular class this is pretty handy
because it shows how many students
completed the assignment so i know
the present this is um this jeremy is
what i use to
build slides for the next day i can look
at
question seven two students missed that
one got it correct
i know there's not a lot of data here
but i can look at the gray bar and the
green bar if i've got a big green bar
that everybody got it right that's not a
question i need to spend much time on
but if i look and see hey everybody is
missing question number seven i'm going
to
snip that question put it into my slide
deck for the next day
and review that with the uh review that
with the students
so by using assignments you can extract
that data and use that to um
prepare your lesson for the next day
great so i i haven't filmers i mean a
lot of questions about grading coming up
sure and you know a lot of folks are
coming to us totally brand new to con
wondering okay
you know you've got this awesome
advantage mark in the sense that you've
been doing this for years now
if you're just starting this week for
the first time what kind of
recommendations you have for someone in
that position
okay um first off there's a ton of
resources
within khan academy where there's new
teacher guides and
that question is asked all the time so
there's some pretty good resources that
that khan has that khan has available
and i think um
yeah so um jeremy is steering you to
that
steering you to that right now but i
guess i couldn't really give a blanket
answer to that what i would say is
assess your needs are you interested in
using con for assessment
are you using it for your curriculum is
it enrichment
is it practice is it remediation i guess
most of us aren't doing standardized
tests this year so there's probably not
as much test prep
but i think thinking about how you plan
to use khan
the answer will will vary based on what
what teachers are planning to do
and what needs khan can fill i will say
that the um
khan can meet the needs of all of these
things here
so i think that i've used it
successfully for uh for all of those
things
um so if your need is in any of those
areas khan could con could work for you
that's great let's just take sort of the
most simple use case where
maybe a teacher has not been in touch
with their students for a couple of
weeks
now because of lack of technology or
equity issues
and they've only now just gotten the
green light like you've shown on the
screen here
to actually move forward if they just
wanted to get started just get a class
set up just get maybe an assignment or
two out there
how would you even begin that process
it's so easy
um could you just walk us through
setting up a new class
um it really is it really is pretty
simple what we're seeing here in
jeremy's screen is that
he's got these classes created already
in the upper right hand corner
it says add new class so um
we'd click on that and give the class a
name
i just call it demo class or whatever we
want to call it yep
click next
and then this will give you some courses
to choose from i want to teach
kindergarten math today so let's choose
uh that's what i want to set so we just
choose that class click next and just to
be clear like
you can actually choose multiple of
these and tim vandenberg the other
ambassador you were talking about
actually takes his sixth graders and has
them work
grade by grade to fill in any gaps they
have in their learning foundation so it
could be a way to cover those kind of
gaps using this time
yeah and actually i'm glad you mentioned
that um our school is now using um
eureka math for our curriculum
and it's it's super that khan is aligned
with eureka math
so for my eureka math curriculum i can
use
cons content that is designed for eureka
math um
every day and then um this this area
where we um where we add students to our
class and create the class and there's
there's a number of different ways to do
that
what i do jeremy is have students join
with a class link so
with eighth grade students i'm generally
fairly successful with getting
students to create accounts on their own
i don't you know after a week or so i
really don't have any stragglers
um if if there are students that kind of
lag i bring them into a meeting a
one-on-one meeting and help them
through the process and get them set up
but it's really um
getting it set up is pretty
straightforward and there's a number of
different options that
that have worked for teachers to do that
so you could just copy and paste that
into an email
or an lms or a reminder class dojo style
tool
and send that out so right so that link
will uh we'll put the students into
into the class and then uh what i can do
as an instructor if i have
assignments created for the kids then i
can refresh my class list
and that automatically gives our active
assignments to the the new students that
have joined
the class and so just to fast forward
just one final step here
if you want to get that first assignment
out how would you even sort of take that
first step
uh let's see so if we want to we're just
starting the year we're starting algebra
one
and um i want the students to i want
them to watch that video
about origins of algebra so i would
click origins of algebra video
um i don't think algebra's that
beautiful so i wouldn't assign
the the beauty of algebra you know just
kind of scroll down through
and in the assignments you can assign
videos like we've done there
can we scroll down a little bit here uh
if you guys look over on the left hand
side
you'll see a triangle that that
indicates that it's a video that's being
assigned the little thing that looks
like a piece of paper
is an article about the topic and then
the pencil
indicates a practice exercise so you
know what i want to assign the video the
article and the
the uh the video the article and the
practice exercise for that one
so we assign all three of those if you
look at the top you'll see how many
things are being assigned there's three
assignments that we're creating
we click that
and then we can choose the due date for
the assignment
you can see that right there what class
i'm assigning it to if you have multiple
classes when you want it turned in
which students you want that assigned to
what time of day it is due
and the top is kind of interesting
because you have the ability to choose
whether it's randomized questions so
questions are pulled from the
the bank of questions and each student
gets different questions or
you can choose so that all the students
are working on the exact same questions
so that when they start asking
i typically do randomize for easier
assignments and then
we'll do the same question for all
students when it's a
a more difficult assignment great okay
so that's definitely
the sort of like one two three steps of
like getting a new class started
enrolling your students making the first
assignment
now let's come back to that sort of next
thing you were going to speak about
which were other ideas
for sort of extending um your
teacher's pedagogy into this new digital
world right and
maybe let's see do i want to do this
slide do you want to do more specifics
or
general here jeremy the last slide of
the day is kind of uh we know what no
let's do let's do this this is fine
um what i would say and this is
something that that i've learned
from cyber teaching is that the snipping
tool
that that most students have available
as a is
um part of the windows tool suite is so
important i use that a lot and train the
kids early on in the school year
how to snip a question so they're
looking at something their con
assignment
they can snip the assignment and then
post it on my screen so that i can see
exactly what they're looking at so
students aren't
trying to type in or write on the board
what their question is because a lot of
times
they'll do that they'll forget oh they
forget a negative sign
then they enter the answer and it's mr
laser this answer's wrong well
if you use the snipping tool you can see
exactly what the students are
are looking at and we use that day in
and day out
in my in my classroom
um and then what jeremy is showing there
is just um the
the microsoft directions for how to use
the uh
uh the snipping tool to a snip and post
on a page
um that's what i use for um for static
content
and here at my desk again since i just
got out of office hours i have my uh
bamboo pen and digital pen it's it's
kind of like what sal
uses when he does his lessons again this
is something that is just invaluable it
allows me to write on the board uh work
through problems with students so that i
can share
um so that i can share i can actually
write on the screen and it's a lot less
cumbersome than trying to write with a
uh
trying to write with a mouse or trying
to do things in a in chat
yeah i've noticed um sal using his wacom
tablet and his wacom stylus and
um he's just super fast with that i
think you're the same way mark so
definitely cool it it really comes in
handy i would be uh i'd be lost without
it i really uh i
use it uh use it every day then um and
when i say static i mean if it's just a
fixed question if it's just one plus one
equals and i want to snip that question
and then write
i do that i use um screen sharing or
application sharing for dynamic content
um some of khan's content involves
rotating things or moving things or
doing translations transformations that
sort of thing
and when the content moves when you want
to move it around
um that's more difficult to do with the
snipping tool what i'll have students do
is share
and then i'll um can kind of walk
students through or answer questions
looking at it
looking at it live and i think there was
some questions about that like how often
students are doing screen sharing or
sharing their screen versus
how often i use the whiteboard probably
eighty to ninety percent of the class is
uh the white board and the snipping tool
and then when we get into um when we get
into lessons where
the the con content is dynamic then
we'll use the uh
the screen sharing and just to be clear
like are students sharing their own
screens or you're primarily the share of
your screen
uh i i share my slide deck so
like what we're doing right here so
we'll share that
um students
in my class don't often share their
screen they'll they'll take a snip and
share something that they're looking at
or if i want them to share if we're
trying to troubleshoot something they'll
share it but
more often than not it's just um it's
static and we're using the snipping tool
cool that's great and obviously a lot of
folks are being trained up right now on
zoom and google hangouts and all these
different tools and
they all have screen sharing built in
yep yep um the rule of 24 is just um
something that one of our math teachers
now administrators taught me about
preparing presentations for class and
that's just use a minimum font of 24
and that obviously may vary but just um
the idea is to to keep your
keep your slide deck screen clean and
presentable and not have a lot of
a lot of small print on them just uh
something to make it easier for users
um checking for understanding one of the
things that is a disadvantage in the
cyber environment
is um we we don't have cameras on the
students so
for privacy reasons we're not doing what
you and i are doing right now jeremy
where we can look and see each other
i can't see the student so it's more
difficult to check for understanding
because i can't look out at a classroom
of faces and see
oh they're getting this or oh man they
are totally confused
so very important to check for
understanding using any kind of
tools that you have available within
your software platform for presenting it
or
something like um google documents i use
pretty heavily for exit ticket questions
to
check for understanding at the end of a
lesson to make sure that students uh
understand the concept and the content
that's being presented
would you need a google form or
something exactly what i i typically use
google quizzes
i just make a real simple quiz that um
asks them
their name and it can it can be anything
you want you could be
you know did you understand today's
lesson or you could take
uh you could take a question from khan
um snip it and put it in there something
from another learning resource
uh something from a state assessment i
typically don't do super difficult
questions for the exit ticket question
because we're not there to discuss it
sometimes we'll do a you know a
challenge or a bonus question
that's part of that but uh checking for
understanding is pretty important and
even more so i think in a cyber
environment than
uh than brick and mortar just because
it's more difficult to do in a cyber
environment
great um personalizing just um
making sure that you kind of fit the
needs of the class and that's why i use
those um
you know i am typically updating my
slides right up until the moment the
class starts with the latest data on how
students are doing and any problems that
they might be struggling with
i really try to keep my lesson
presentation simple i don't use a lot of
video i don't do a lot of
even screen sharing like we're doing can
tend to bog things down
and uh students that don't have good
robust internet connection it will
start to uh have them they'll start to
glitch out
so i really try to keep things with with
pretty much uh
a pretty straightforward uh slide deck
for the presentation of the lesson
and keep things light um you know once
once students start to understand your
sense of humor and you understand theirs
you can make it kind of a fun
a fun environment
great and you know i know that we're
running a little short on time would you
be okay mark
some questions from the audience or i
know i know our time goes fast here yeah
why don't we just
if we can just kind of zoom through the
deck and see if is there anything else
that we absolutely positively had to
share from the deck oh
this is something that's really
important we kind of talked about this
um uh jeremy a little bit um
one of the things that for teachers that
are new to khan or just joining one of
the things i really really like about
khan is that
i never hear khan is down like oh we
can't do what we wanted to because
you know kids can't access the website
or kind of that just
in the the years and years that i've
been using that is just so infrequent
that's not something you really even
need to plan for
and also and this is really nice i
rarely have a situation where students
say the answer is
wrong no wait i shouldn't say that i
rarely have situations where students
say this answer is wrong
and they're right about that a lot of
times they'll say kahn doesn't have the
right answer here and when you dig in
you find out it's right so
you can present this material with a
high degree of confidence in that
i would anticipate jeremy lots of
questions about on how to set up the
class roster
about navigation we've had some
difficulty in matching
the eureka curriculum with the exact con
lessons that we want to teach so some
things like that where you need to
work to massage the curriculum you know
figuring out exactly what your routine
is going to be and there's some data
that i'd like to be able to export from
khan that we can't currently
but those are kind of the main
challenges when i surveyed my teaching
colleagues at agora
those are some of the the things that
they mentioned
um yeah i don't think there's anything
super important here that we need to
share if you want to jump into the
questions these are
these were more general things that uh i
will hide out this that is first of all
i think this is so important
um i actually have stats from inside con
that says something like
only 10 or 20 of new teachers to khan
ever play with the content themselves
before starting to assign it
and i think that's actually a huge
missed opportunity that's on our
shoulders at con for not making it easy
but one of the first things you should
absolutely do is just put yourself in
your student's shoes
see what the content looks like what it
feels like how the hint system works and
that way when you give it out
you have that confidence that mark was
talking about because you've been there
and you've been you've developed that
empathy
with the student experience yeah that
brings up something really interesting
that i didn't touch on before when you
create your class roster i always add
myself to whatever class i create
so that when i do assignments i see
exactly the assignments that are going
to students
and the third bullet there do every
assignment that you give to your
students just make sure that you you
know
what the uh what the questions look like
how khan goes about solving them
and again that's kind of that empathy
that jeremy mentioned so you understand
what students are
going through and jeremy just as an
aside on that after mr vandenberg's
presentation
and and going back to sixth grade i've
been working with my students on third
grade content
and i had never looked at khan's third
grade content
there's some really good stuff in there
that i'd never even you know i'd never
even seen before
but it's uh it's some really good uh
really good stuff
i love that okay so on that note let's
take some of these questions because
these are really great questions for you
so
i want to start with an awesome one from
haman humong says
how do you help students track their own
progress
when we're so distant from them we're so
disconnected from them but
we want to empower them to direct their
own learning at this moment
so how do you get them evaluating how
they're doing sure
um is this uh is this a student or a
teacher do you have a student loaded
yeah so we can definitely come into the
learner mode here so yeah let's go
learn her home okay so if i'm megan
patani
and i want to know how i'm how i'm doing
um one thing that's really important you
guys as you're getting to know khan
sometimes students will say my data is
not recording
you know i answer this make sure that in
the upper right hand corner you see the
student's name
make sure that they're logged into con
sometimes students will accidentally log
out and they're working away and they
don't realize that they're not
that they're not logged in but let's say
that we want to find out how megan is
doing
and this this is megan megan wants to
see how she's doing
in algebra one um we can look right
there at algebra one we can click on
that you see that she's mastered sixteen
percent of the course so far
course wraps up on may 15th we can open
that and we can see
megan did extremely well on algebra
foundations earning
700 out of 700 mastery points so
kind of those assignments that we looked
at earlier with the origin and history
of algebra and that sort of thing
she's done a little bit of work on
solving equations and inequalities let's
click on that and see what's going on
in that in that particular module
so this shows as jeremy scrolls down
through this you can see she
she's done very well in equations with
variables on both sides
now as we get into linear equations with
parentheses it looks like that's where
she um
she stopped we don't have any work for
uh equations with parentheses and
decimals and fractions
so megan could go in and see okay i've
mastered this first module now it's time
to go on to the second module and khan
is pretty good about prompting
and once you kind of teach students how
to do the navigation they'll be able to
figure out where to go
you know where the next step in their
learning progression is
great and so really if you teach
students sort of review these summaries
on the left hand side
they can start to think of this as hey i
want to have all these bars filled up
i want to master every single course
skill here and it's almost a challenge
to them for the rest of the year
can they make it to that point of
mastery because that could be a big
point of pride
yeah you want to see a lot of purple
over there that's right um
here's another technology question i
don't know if it's one that you face
because maybe your students will have
laptops but any recommendations for
um teachers out there who know their
students don't have computers at home
but may have access to a mobile phone
their parent's smartphone do you feel
like the khan academy app is a
worthwhile thing to look at
it's coming from daisy i can't really
comment on that
i don't um i haven't worked with
students specifically on
i know that students do access it or our
students all have laptops
and i know when students have a dentist
appointment or something like that
they'll say hey mr laser
i'm doing this on my mom's phone or
something like that but i don't really
have i don't think
enough track record with mobile apps um
i know it's available
but um um most of our students don't
access it that way
okay makes sense and i'll just say for
the benefit of daisy and everyone else
out there
um this can often be a lifeline to you
if there is only one single device in
the house
and there's a smartphone while you can't
use
teacher tools on the app so everything
that mark has just talked through is
limited to the
online website students get a complete
view of everything on this
on the course right there on their phone
so it is a way to sort of make sure that
there's more access
a little more equity okay um great
question
so um and
one thing about that con tends to be
pretty
thin bandwidth wise it it's it runs
pretty well on a wide variety of
devices i i rarely have any problems
with students who
you know have extreme problems with the
speed that cons loading or anything like
that
um this is a lot of technology questions
coming your way mark because i think
you've definitely shown your your
credibility here uh kakai wants to know
do you have any recommendations for best
practices with integrating with lms's
be it schoology google classroom
whatever
no i don't unfortunately our our my con
grade book doesn't speak to my grade
book currently so i have to export from
con and then reimport that into my grade
book
the curriculum that i do i've built
pretty much in cons so it doesn't need
the link with anything else i've
i've pretty much turned off our school
curriculum and then i use
a con curriculum that i've built based
on eureka for that so i don't really um
i'm trying to think i don't really do
much integration but any um
digital integration between khan and the
other systems that are that our school
uses
makes sense and i think all i was going
to add was that
obviously while there's not a very
formal integration i have seen students
or teachers come right up and after
making an assignment
they will actually choose a specific
piece of work
because the nice thing is that
everything on con has its own individual
url
and they'll copy this url and they'll
paste it into lms or paste it into
google classroom
and that way not only does the student
have the assignment in their email or on
their app
but they also have it in that lms that
central source of truth
okay so you've just you've just prompted
me for something there that's exactly
what i do i've got a big spreadsheet
that
has the date the topic um the con
help resource for the day and then the
con assessment resource for the day
and that's all loaded into our school
system it doesn't happen automatically
but like jeremy said the urls are there
so that students can access that
great and then i want to finish up with
two final questions if you don't mind
mark i apologize for going a little bit
over
um i'm curious
number one is for the folks who didn't
have a chance to answer their questions
today
what resources would you recommend to
continue the learning around con or
continue the learning around remote
learning
um as they go into the next few weeks i
would direct
every question to jeremy that's jeremy
khan and i think jeremy's going to be
sharing his home phone number with us
also
so call him any hour of the day or night
24 7. jeremy's there to
no i i would um uh reach out to the khan
user groups on facebook
um super helpful group of people there
and then
the um the online help in khan
is um you know within within the khan
website
uh is the zen the zendesk
help there's so much good information
there and the same questions get asked
so many times
that there's some really good printable
resources on
how to get started as a teacher how to
get started as a student if you're a
parent trying to figure this out
how to get started as a parent there's
some really good guide there
that does serve as a really good
starting point and again um
we've all been where where everybody is
right now we've all been
just trying to use it trying to get
started and trying to get things figured
out
and there's a ton of resources there
that that are
that are quite helpful very cool and
then last question
is just if you were in the shoes of many
of the educators in this country right
now
who are trying to figure out like what
am i going to do next how am i going to
get through the next several weeks or
even months
any words of wisdom that you can offer
folks as we begin this week
it's going to make a great story someday
right once we get through this we'll
remember uh we'll
certainly remember 20 20. no just um i
think i might have put that in one of
the last slides that we're all in this
together
you know the goal here is to help our
kids and help keep moving them forward
using
whatever tools we have at our disposal
to do that um
you know i i thought that um i'm always
looking for different ways to to use con
and to improve it and
mr vandenberg's discussions just within
the last two weeks have been super
eye-opening giving me some things
that i want to try so um you are not
alone
uh we're all we're all in this together
and we're all here to uh
to help each other out so uh boy good
luck to uh good luck to everybody
um you know we're all in this together
awesome well i think that's definitely
the the right theme to start this tough
week on
and i want to thank you mark for really
embodying that advice
by taking time out of your own teaching
schedule today to share your expertise
with others
i hope that you will take advantage of
all the resources that mark has shared
and we'll share this deck and we'll
share all the slides with you right
afterwards
and we wish you all a good week and a
good start to the rest of the month
thank you all so much
you